as you can see we're getting pretty
close to our mock-up but the page looks
a little bland of course we don't have
the right colors over here and it also
looks like the text isn't formatted
quite the same either
notice how in the mock-up we're right
aligned but over here on our site right
now or on the left also notice how this
name in title are both in all caps while
ours are capitalized normally check out
bootstraps documentation to see if there
are any classes that'll help you easily
fix things like alignment and
capitalization I recommend checking out
the typography section this is a
two-part question in the first part pick
the classes that you need to write a
line text in make text all uppercase for
the second part of this question which
of these elements need the classes that
you've defined up here div class equal
Rho div class equals column medium six
or is it the h1 header and h3 header
check all that apply